foreign
California and talk to Taylor Hey Taylor
what's up
good morning Dr John thank you for
taking my call of course thanks for
calling what's happening
so the reason why I'm calling is because
I want to be prepared for when my
daughter starts asking me questions
about my past
and her childhood and a little bit of
how old is how old is your daughter
she's uh
almost she's not there yet but she I
want that's why I want to be prepared
okay I think I know where this is going
but you can surprise me so go ahead
Okay so
so had a severe drug addiction for
almost 10 years from the age of 16 to
about 25 what'd you use um I went uh
heroin and meth okay
do you have a rough childhood
um yeah yeah I would say so
you started with um
it was pretty bad it was pretty bad
wasn't it
well it yes it was um it's hard for me I
don't know I don't like holding that
against my mom I just I think she did
the best she could and my dad too he was
an alcoholic and ended up dying from
that so when did he when did he pass
away
um and
and so yeah before we get going this is
important
the fact that you're calling and asking
this question
is
um it's important and I'm really proud
of you it's awesome you've been sober
for how long
over four years now that's incredible
especially from those two demons because
those two demons are gnarly nothing and
heroin are tough
yeah but the fact that you're asking
this question in the way you're asking
this question
suggest that you are flinching
with the conversation you need to have
with your daughter
and that Flinch comes from shame
and yes I'm sure your mom did the best
she could
but you went through hell
and you grew up in the home of someone
who deeply struggled with addiction and
then your dad died
meth and heroin are often not always but
often relationship duct tape
and so I want you to drop your shoulders
and
man you've got
those two drugs especially you got 10
years of
bad memories two years ten years of
things you wish you could take back that
you did right am I am I right
yeah totally and then you the light came
on
yeah okay I want you to lean more into
the light than into that Darkness okay
okay your daughter's not gonna
experience what you did let me say it
that way
she's got a mom who loves
every ounce of her being fair
yes okay all right now continue go ahead
okay so my main concern is explaining to
so yes explaining to her my past and
also just things about her childhood too
like I was in rehab when she was born
and so there's pictures of me you know
transitioning to a transitional housing
program for women you know she didn't
have a typical like infancy life and so
but I'm also worried that
um her dad and my sister will tell her
like really hurtful things about the
darkest secrets of my past to try to
hurt me and hurt her in a way because
we're not on good terms
um so those are the two things that I'm
really just concerned about and just
yeah explaining it this to her without
causing harm or causing her to resent me
give me an example of something that is
so dark that you're terrified your
daughter's gonna find out
um
to rehab for finding out that I was
pregnant which is horrible
um and there was some talk I I don't
I I wasn't ever serious but just talk
about alternative options as opposed to
going through with the pregnancy
so those are the two big things that um
I think that they would throw at her
maybe just in passing or just so I
missed the first the first one is you
used at the beginning of your pres
pregnancy
yeah okay and does your daughter have
any cognitive delays or any
um no she does not okay physical delay
she's good to go rocking and rolling
yeah
beautiful rambunctious knucklehead of a
kid
yes
yes it's awesome
okay
so just for just for the nuts and bolts
until she's 12 or 13.
any questions or conversations that come
up
you were sick and the medicine you were
using was dangerous and not good
why Mom I was really sick
and some of the sick hurt my heart and
some of the sick hurt my head and it
really clouded my decisions I made some
not good choices
that's it okay
that's it
if your sister or
the father of this child
decides to
throw a nuclear weapon into the heart of
the little girl and tell her that your
mom was considering terminating the
pregnancy they can do that
and if your daughter ever comes to you
and says Dad said this that you were
thinking about having abortion when
you're pregnant with me
you can say I was very sick I was really
scared
and then I thought of you and I thought
of this moment right here and then you
pull your kid close and you hug him for
an obnoxious amount of time 10 seconds
20 seconds 30 seconds without without
letting go
okay okay
I didn't do that I know you can
you've done way harder
the hardest thing in this Con in this
transaction is not talking to your
daughter and answering hard questions
you've been doing that for a long time
the hardest thing I'm hearing right here
is that Taylor's got to forgive Taylor
I do and you haven't yet and let me tell
you something really hard I don't want
to pile on you okay but I'm gonna tell
you the truth
if you don't forgive Taylor
in every interaction you have with your
beautiful little baby girl
is one of a flinch
is one of
a spirit of apology
that little girl will sense that and
feel that and make that interaction her
fault and she'll spend her whole life
trying to solve it
okay be fully reckless in your love for
this little girl
she won the lottery when she got you as
her mom
oh thank you do you have some stuff you
shouldn't have done yes we all do
we all do
okay
now
this is important do not use your
daughter as a way to make yourself feel
better
what I mean by that is or or to get
things off your chest
cool
yes do you mean like it's just venting
to her is that what you mean
um I mean things like
you feel like as she gets older and your
relationship gets Tighter and Tighter
that there's going to be this
set like this gap between you because
you've got secrets that she doesn't know
about
she's not your romantic partner she's
not your best friend she's not your
pastor
there's going to be parts of your life
that she will hopefully never know about
yeah and there may be a time when she
does something dumb when she's 12 or 13
which all 12 and 13 year olds do and
she'll say something 12 and 13 year
oldish like you don't know you don't
understand and then you can be like hold
my beer like for real except you're not
drinking so hold my diet coke and I got
some stories to tell you
and my friend Rachel Cruz says Cher
don't scare right so if there's moments
that they're gonna ask uh that you can
contribute great but don't use your kid
as a as a trash can for the stuff that
you've done in an effort to try to quote
unquote make the relationship
transparent
okay keep this in your soul answer
questions that you are asked
or if you notice her pulling back or
starting to change directions or
starting to get give her opportunities
to ask questions here's the best way to
do that she's four years old now
yes what's your custody arrangement
he is I have full physical and legal
custody he uh is not willing or able to
get sober okay so so yeah
the conversation should always be Daddy
sick
he's very very sick we're not ever going
to talk bad about Dad
and I want you to create starting now a
a special thing that you and this little
girl do every week
if you ever listen to the show you'll
like you'll one day I'm gonna get
sponsored by Waffle House
um kind of goes against my diet the way
I I think it's healthy to eat but
um I started taking my son to Waffle
House every Tuesday morning before
school
for great conversations for a great way
to get to know each other sometimes we
read a book together but here was the
the main goal I'm playing a 15 or 20
year game
not game I'm playing a 15 or I'm
planting seeds for our relationship that
will that will come above ground in 5 10
15 20 years and that is
dad loves me
and there is not a thing I can't tell
him
where his first impulse won't be to say
I love you
yeah and so if you wait until there's a
big kerfuffle or a big issue or as all
young kids ask is what happened to Dad
and there's gonna be questions she asked
what was so great about whatever dad's
using that he chose that over me that's
a common kid question and that's a fair
question and a valid question even if
it's not exactly how it plays out in
real life
those are hard moments the kids try to
solve those in all those crazy ways what
we want is three or four or five years
of relational Capital built up so that
when you look at her and say Daddy's
sick has nothing to do with you
you are loved that she'll go okay I
trust you because you've put that time
in
see what I'm saying
yes I do okay
and you don't have to hold back your
tears all the time you're worth crying
too I've heard you on this call man
you're hanging in there you're tough
stop being so tough
you've had to be tough for like 15 years
right
yes yes
you're too fun and you're too good of a
mom and you're too good of a friend to
be tough all the time being tough kind
of sucks
be tough in moments
obviously be disciplined all the time
but man
drop the shoulders
you've done some amazing work
that little girl one with you
set the bricks you're caring about
Taylor down
Taylor had a hard row
and Taylor's Still Standing Tall
after all the shots were fired and all
the smoke is clear Taylor is Still
Standing Tall
when everyone around her fail fell or
bailed or passed away Taylor's still
standing strong holding a beautiful
little girl
you're incredible proud of you